amtsmissbrauch und vertuschung die nun
veröffentlichte beschwerde eines
whistleblowers setzt us-präsident
schramm weiter unter druck
transparenz oder selbstbestimmung darf
man polizisten dazu verpflichten
namensschild oder nummer zu tragen ja
urteilte das bundesverwaltungsgericht
tower umsatz chirac frankreichs
ehemaliger präsident stirbt im alter von
86 jahren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute nachrichten um 19 uhr den
sport hat diesmal rudi cerne für uns
dabei in einer viertelstunde in ovalen
viertelstunde hallo und guten abend in
der ukraine affäre gerät us-präsident
trump weiter unter druck
ein geheimdienstmitarbeiter gab zu
protokoll dass das weiße haus offenbar
versucht hat die aufzeichnung des
umstrittenen telefongesprächs mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten selensky unter
verschluss zu halten
neue munition für die demokraten und ihr
geplantes amtsenthebungsverfahren die
hürden für einen impeachment sind aber
sehr hoch gegen drei us präsidenten
wurden bislang verfahren eingeleitet
seines amtes enthoben wurde keine dazu
müssten beide parlamentskammern
zustimmen zunächst das
repräsentantenhaus dann der senat und
dort haben trumps republikaner die
mehrheit
britta jäger berichtet auf den liberalen
us nachrichtenkanälen überschlagen sich
die journalisten die beschwerde des
whistleblowers die das weiße haus unter
verschluss halten wollte ist raus der
inhalt brisant zitat offizielle harmonie
erzählt sie seien vom weißen haus
angewiesen worden das elektronische
transkript des gesprächs aus dem
computersystem zu entfernen um die wort
genaue aufzeichnung dann so schiller der
anonyme geheimdienstler als vertraulich
einzustufen hat trump also sein amt für
seinen persönlichen nutzen missbraucht
und zu vertuschen was er mit seinem
ukrainischen amtskollegen talents
gesprochen hatte bisher schildert nur
ein wohl lückenhaftes
gedächtnisprotokoll wie die beiden im
juli erst über us militärhilfen sprachen
und trump dann ermittlungen forderte
gegen den möglichen demokratischen
präsidentschaftskandidaten biden und
dessen sohn
die demokraten glauben an
verfassungsbruch sie sehen sich
bestätigt
wenn da etwas ist mit dem sich der
präsident politische vorteile verschafft
die leute das nicht wissen sollen
und er ist deshalb versteckt dann ist
das vertuschung der geheimdienstchef
lieferte ihnen keine neue munition
seine anhörung erklärte josef meyer
warum er die beschwerde des
whistleblowers nicht sofort
weiterleitete wir haben den
rechtsberater des weißen hauses
konsultiert und es wurde uns gesagt dass
nur der präsident über diese
informationen verfügen kann
lasst uns zusammenstehen ihr spiel
spielen und hart kämpfen schwört trump
seine republikaner auf twitter ein
unser land steht auf dem spiel seine
präsidentschaft wohl auch da fragen wir
unseren amerika korrespondenten elmar
theveßen immer jetzt den die vorwürfe
des whistleblowers bekannt gibt dass dem
amtsenthebungsverfahren einen neuen
schub auf jeden fall schub man könnte es
auch zu nennen denn es gibt schon streit
in der sache natürlich bei der anhörung
vorhin haben einige der demokraten auch
kurz schlüsse gezogen oder urteile
gefällt ohne dass bereits alle beweise
auf dem tisch liegen und das ist
natürlich dann wieder munition für die
republikaner die das ganze als eine
parodie abtun und die beschwerde des
whistleblowers als reine gerüchteküche
aber man muss klar sagen das was hier
drin steht in dieser beschwerde hat sehr
viel substanz der beschwerdeführer
beruft sich auf mindestens ein dutzend
zeugen die diese vorgänge im weißen haus
ihm geschildert haben und diesen zeugen
muss man jetzt nachgehen sie vor laden
auch vor dem kongress sogar der chef der
nachrichtendienste hat diese beschwerde
als glaubhaft bezeichnet also da gibt es
genug stoff um wirklich ein ordentliches
amtsenthebungsverfahren zu führen
wie wird sich das engagement denn im
wahlkampf auswirken
ja es ist natürlich ein spektakel und
das droht dann eben den sauerstoff
gewissermaßen allen sachthemen
abzudrehen um die man sonst im wahlkampf
streiten würde gesundheit wirtschaft
arbeit all diese themen und da geht es
vielleicht in erster linie am ende darum
wer ist das größere opfer ist es joe
biden der ehemalige vizepräsident jetzt
auch kandidat der möglicherweise ziel
von schmutzkampagnen werden sollten die
der amerikanische präsident versucht
haben soll aus der ukraine zu bekommen
oder ist es umgekehrt us-präsident trump
der sich jetzt schon als märtyrer
darstellt und sei
der würde durch diese amtsenthebung oder
dieses verfahren gehindert sich um das
wohl der nation zu kümmern also es wird
ein spektakel mit ungewissem ausgang
vielen dank elmer nach washington nach
deutschland der reiseveranstalter thomas
cook deutschland hat alle reisen bis zum
oktober abgesagt auch wenn sie schon
bezahlt sind grundsätzlich ist für diese
fälle jetzt die insolvenz versicherung
zuständig neue reisen können nicht mehr
gebucht werden aktuell sind nach angaben
des unternehmens noch etwa 70.000 thomas
cook pauschalurlauber aus deutschland
unterwegs
der bundestag hat das ende der stasi
unterlagen behörde beschlossen die akten
wandern nun in außenstellen des
bundesarchivs ehemalige
ddr-bürgerrechtler üben kritik
sie warnen davor einen schlussstrich zu
ziehen die behörde gilt als eines der
vermächtnisse der wende
seit 1992 haben bürger journalisten und
wissenschaftler das recht dort dokumente
des ministeriums für staatssicherheit
einzusehen
cornelia schiemenz im januar 1990 stürmt
das volk der ddr die stasi hauptzentrale
in berlin
der endgültige sieg über das
unrechtssystem fordern wird das erbe der
spitze gesichert aufgearbeitet den
opfern zur verfügung gestellt seit 1992
in der stasi unterlagenbehörde im
bundestag sprachen sich heute alle
fraktionen mit ausnahme der afg für eine
überführung der stasi
hinterlassenschaften in das bundesarchiv
aus fit machen für die zukunft und die
gesamtdeutsche verarbeitung stärken wir
wollen ressourcen bündeln digitalisieren
archiv gerecht lagern
es drängt sich der eindruck auf dass der
stift
gesetzt werden soll zu einem
schlussstrich unter die aufarbeitung der
verbrechen des sed-regimes künftig soll
es je ostland nur noch einen archiv
standort geben das amt des
bundesbeauftragten wird abgeschafft
akteneinsicht für opfer ist dauerhaft
möglich
doch auch ehemalige ddr bürgerrechtler
kritisieren die abwicklung in einem
offenen brief schreiben sie aufarbeitung
ist auch politische bildung eine
ausdünnung wäre angesichts wachsender
politikmüdigkeit nicht nur in
ostdeutschland kontraproduktiv
geschichte lässt sich nicht abwickeln
ich verstehe viele menschen die sich
sorge machen aber darum geht es ja
dieses symbol der friedlichen revolution
ja in die nächsten jahrzehnte zu tragen
und deswegen verändern wir damit ja
zukunft 16
das interesse jedenfalls ist ungebrochen
allein 2018 wurden 45.000 anträge auf
akteneinsicht gestellt
gestern abend gab die ezb bekannt sabine
lautenschläger will sich vorzeitig aus
dem direktorium der notenbank
zurückziehen
heute bekräftigt die bundesregierung den
anspruch deutschlands auf den posten
man werde in kürze eine geeignete
kandidatin beziehungsweise einen
geeigneten kandidaten als nachfolger
benennen
lautenschläger hat immer wieder kritik
geübt am kurs der europäischen
zentralbank vor allem an den
milliardenschweren anleihenkäufen können
polizeibeamte verpflichtet werden im
dienst namensschilder zu tragen ja hat
das bundesverwaltungsgericht in leipzig
entschieden
in sechs bundesländern arbeiten
polizisten weitgehend anonym
in neun sind die beamten grundsätzlich
verpflichtet ein namensschild oder
wenigstens eine nummer zu tragen
zwei polizisten aus brandenburg sehen
dadurch ihre persönlichkeitsrechte
verletzt und fürchten um ihre sicherheit
jan meyer berichtet
namensschilder an polizeiuniformen
brandenburg war das erste bundesland das
sie 2013 verpflichtend einführte
die beiden polizisten fürchten dass
dadurch die gefahr von angriffen auf
beamte größer wird die
polizeigewerkschaft teilt ihre bedenken
also die sorgen sind dahingehend dass ja
immer mehr durch die neue technik im
video aufzeichnung et cetera pp und
mitnahmen und dann über internet die
chance ganz schnell
der beamte selbst oder seine familie
herausgefunden werden kann und daneben
haben unsere kollegen die große sorge
dass sie in ihrer privatsphäre verletzt
werden nach auffassung des
bundesverwaltungsgerichts ist die
kennzeichnungspflicht dennoch
verfassungsgemäß denn sie macht es
leichter solche polizisten zu
identifizieren die dienstpflichten
verletzen oder straftaten begingen
das sind es gesetzes und zweck ist
transparenz und bürgernähe herzustellen
und außerdem eine im nachhinein
strafverfolgung zu lassen falls etwas
passieren sollte falls etwas geschehen
sollte das urteil bezieht sich zwar nur
auf polizisten in brandenburg gilt aber
im grundsatz für alle
doch erst neun bundesländer verwenden
namensschilder andere bundesländer die
auf eine kennzeichnung verzichten wird
wie bayern oder niedersachsen müssen
diese nach dem urteil nicht einführen
angesichts der klaren worte des gerichts
müssen sie sich aber politisch fragen
lassen warum sie auf bessere aufklärung
von rechtsverstößen durch polizisten
verzichten den beiden brandenburger
polizisten steht nun nur noch der weg
zum bundesverfassungsgericht in
karlsruhe offen
nach einer gruppenvergewaltigung in
düsseldorf im juni hat die polizei jetzt
vier jugendliche festgenommen sie sollen
eine 51 jahre alte frau in einem park
gelockt vergewaltigt und ausgeraubt
haben
zwei der minderjährigen verdächtigen
sind als intensivtäter bekannt durch
ihre dna am tatort kamen in die fahnder
auf die spur
bei allen festgenommenen handelt es sich
um ausländer ihre nationalität wollten
die ermittler mit hinweis auf deren
alter nicht nennen anker zentren waren
das kernstück des sogenannten
masterplans migration von
bundesinnenminister seehofer
und bayern ersetzte als erstes
bundesland seine
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen durch die
umstrittenen zentren
dabei steht die abkürzung anker etwa für
ankunft kommunale verteilung
entscheidung und rückführung in bayern
werden so an sieben standorten alle
zuständigen behörden unter einem dach
gebündelt das ziel schnelle und
effiziente asylverfahren doch heute gab
es im landtag im landtag herbe kritik
guter sonne wald sie durchbrechen eine
mauer aus umzugskartons mit dieser
aktion vor dem bayerischen landtag
fordert der flüchtlingsrat die
abschaffung von anker zentren
geflüchtete würden in solchen massen
unterkünften von der gesellschaft
isoliert so die kritik sie kommt auch
von asylbewerbern das leben im anker
zentrum bamberg ist ein leben ohne
ausbildung und ohne arbeitet schluss
sind von unserer zimmer und wenn
schlafen wir oder
bleiben sie zu hause jeden tag
gekommen
die aufenthaltsdauer hat sich nur für
diejenigen mit einer guten
bleibeperspektive verkürzt 80 prozent
der asylsuchenden müssen laut caritas
länger als ein jahr in solchen zentren
ausharren zu lang vor allem für kinder
kritisieren experten die heute zu einer
anhörung im bayerischen landtag geladen
waren die kinderrechte in anker zentren
werden nicht umgesetzt
das recht auf ruhe das recht auf
privatsphäre
das recht auf seelische gesundheit
darüber hinaus dürfen kinder in anker
zentren keine schule besuchen
während kritiker für kleinere dezentrale
unterbringungsformen plädieren
verteidigt das bundesamt für migration
und flüchtlinge
wie die bayerische regierung das konzept
der anker zentren
wir sind zwar insgesamt schon sehr
schnell geworden mit den asylverfahren
den anker einige noch mal schneller
doch bei metro skater hat das nicht
geklappt mehr als zwei jahre war er mit
seiner familie im anker zentrum
ingolstadt vor kurzem durften sie
ausziehen
ob sie langfristig in deutschland
bleiben dürfen ist immer noch nicht
entschieden
im nordfranzösischen rouen brennt seit
dem frühen morgen eine chemiefabrik
offenbar hatten sich mehrere explosionen
ereignet verletzt wurde aber niemand
das unternehmen gehört zu den
gefährlichen produktionsstandorten die
besonders überwacht werden
inzwischen ist das feuer unter kontrolle
anwohner sollen den rauch meiden schulen
und krippen in der region bleiben
vorerst geschlossen
frankreich trauert um einen seiner
prägenden staatsmänner auch deutschland
hat jacques chirac wie es
bundespräsident steinmeier formulierte
viel zu verdanken
der frühere premierminister und
staatspräsident starb heute im alter von
86 jahren
volksnähe zeichnete ihn aus
diplomatische geschick chirac besaß aber
auch einen ausgeprägten machtinstinkt
christel haas erinnert an ihm
er feiert seinen größten erfolg mai 1995
jacques chirac ist gerade zum
präsidenten gewählt worden der den alle
wegen seiner ungestümen direkten art den
bulldozer nennen ist ganz oben
angekommen
eine steile karriere mit 27 berater von
präsident pompidou mit 41
premierminister ein eiliger junger mann
ein machtmensch als erster präsident
frankreichs bricht er mit einem tabu und
erkennt eine mitschuld seines landes an
der deportation von juden im zweiten
weltkrieg an der kriminelle waren der
besatzer wurde von franzosen und vom
französischen staat unterstützt
sein größter außenpolitischer coup 2003
sagt frankreich nein zum irakkrieg und
wird dabei von deutschland und russland
unterstützt
der präsident und die symbole 2004 lag
chirac gerhard schröder als ersten
deutschen kanzler zum jahrestag des d
days in die normandie eine historische
geste europa und die beziehung zu
deutschland standen immer im mittelpunkt
der präsident als charmeur chirac liebt
der schöne frauen und den flirt sehr zum
missfallen seiner ehefrau bernadette
wie kaum ein anderer konnte chirac auf
die menschen zugehen er war ein
genussmensch deshalb liebten ihn viele
franzosen
obwohl es ein offenes geheimnis war dass
er als bürgermeister von paris gelder
unterschlagen hatte nach ende seiner
amtszeit wurde er dafür verurteilt in
den letzten jahren trat nur noch selten
in der öffentlichkeit auf er war schwer
krank
[Applaus]
vom sport und zu die rolle er wurde
heute ein wichtiger schritt für den
deutschen fussball gemacht genau vor
allem und für die zukunft
in der tat ein denkwürdiger tag für den
größten sportverband der welt der
deutsche fußball-bund hat den grundstein
für seine neue akademie in frankfurt am
main gelegt auf einer fläche von neun
hektar umgerechnet fast 14 fußballfelder
entstehen trainingsplätze sporthallen 33
gästezimmer und ein verwaltungsgebäude
geplante kosten 150 millionen euro stand
heute zusammen mit viel fußball
prominenz legte auch bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel bei der feierlichen
zeremonie hand an
in gut zwei jahren soll das
zukunftsprojekt bezugsfertig sein und
helfen den deutschen fußball wieder zur
weltspitze zu führen
wohin konsequente ausbildung führen kann
zeigt das beispiel rb leipzig in der
bundesliga tabellenführer nach fünf
spieltagen trainer julian nagelsmann
genießt vor dem spitzenspiel gegen
schalke 04 den höhenflug ohne dabei
abzuheben
zu recht werden julian nagelsmann und
seine spieler in der presse gelobt
tabellenführung attraktiver fußball und
torgaranten wie timo wärme trotzdem
tritt der trainer auf die euphoriebremse
und schiebt gedanken an die
meisterschaft beiseite das wäre am
fünften spieltag jetzt noch nicht
anfangen am marktplatz in leipzig heißt
ja ich glaube schon den balkon zu
schmücken
das ist glaube ich auch klar großen
respekt zollte nagelsmann seinem
kollegen david wagner
seither sei schalke wieder eine
spitzenmannschaft und wagners verdienste
ist amina riet zu einem stabilen
torgefährlichen spieler zu formen
leipzig tut gut daran den balkon am
markt doch noch nicht zu schmücken
der countdown läuft morgen beginnen die
leichtathletik weltmeisterschaften in
doha die erste wm in einem arabischen
land
die hohen temperaturen werden den 71
deutschen athletinnen und athleten bei
dieser wüsten wm in katar sicher einiges
abverlangen der zeitplan ist sicherlich
den rahmenbedingungen care und den
besonderen temperaturen angemessen hat
alles etwas in die abendstunden
verschoben und wir sind mental darauf
eingestellt und wir übertragen dem zdf
von samstag an petra vielen dank
sonst dass du heute auch gekommen ist
geburtstag gefeiert wird aber später ja
ja und feiern ganz weit oben konnte auch
eine schweizer in den dolomiten dani
arnold schaffte es die anspruchsvollen
nordwand der großen zinne hoch im
eiltempo und ohne absicherung erfahrene
seilschaften brauchen dafür sechs
stunden speed kletterer arnold nur 46
minuten neuer rekord und oben auf dem
fast 3000 meter hohen gipfel gab es
dieses atemberaubende panorama zum
luftholen
tja bei uns scheint die sonne nur im
süden sonst gibt es morgen wieder meist
regen zu den einzelheiten gleich und der
tiere das war es von uns schön dass sie
dabei waren
das sollte schon mal um 21.45 mit claus
kleber und uns geht es morgen wieder
punkt 19 uhr einen gemütlichen abend
noch tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer für viele
geht's ja schon mit regen weiter aber
südlich der donau gibt es morgen
biergartenwetter das tief das uns
derzeit überquert hat ja schon im westen
angefangen zu regnen
das bringt dem süden noch ein schub
warmer luft morgen bevor dort es anfängt
zu regnen vorhaben das regenband quer
über deutschland und auch im westen
lockert dann am späten nachmittag wieder
mehr und mehr auf ja regen heute nach
zunächst im westen dann auch in der
mitte deutschlands zum teil immer mal
kräftig dazu vielleicht mal blitz und
donner
der wind wird auch stärker weht aus süd
bis südwest und im süden bleibt es schon
trocken und das heißt morgen wird es da
erst mal wunderbar sonnig werden aber
weiter nördlich regnet vom saarland
rüber über thüringen bis nach
brandenburg das regendefizit weiter und
abends ist auch münchen dran
mit dem regen sonst wird es am
nachmittag dann schon mal auflockern
hier im nordwesten aber an der nordsee
und in schleswig holstein gibt es dann
auch noch kräftige regenschauer dazu es
bleibt eben windig dabei der wind weht
weiterhin aus dem südwesten und die
temperaturen vor dem regen gehen richtig
in die höhe 24 grad noch meinen bayern
zum teil sonst eben 15 bis 20 grad und
die aussichten in süddeutschland am
wochenende doch freundliches und
sonniges wetter dann kommt in der nacht
zum montag der sturm und danach geht es
ziemlich wechselhaft weiter ihnen noch
einen schönen abend und machen sie's gut